et
on
c'était dommage c'était bien jusque-là
bon que dire
ben je vais essayer de dire impliquent
un petit peu j'essaie de dire quelque
chose vous attendez pas à ce que je dise
quelque chose d'intelligent
déjà parce que c'est difficile mais en
plus parce que j'ai plutôt la réputation
de dire des conneries donc écouté
puisque vous me donner cette opportunité
je vais je vais je vais la saisir mais
quand je vois tous les intervenants qui
sont passés avant je me dis que
forcément partout à chaque fois qu'on
intervient quelque part et a toujours un
connard et quand je vois la qualité des
trucs qui sont passé jusque là j'ai le
gros pressentiment où je sais pas
pourquoi que le lavallois
alors puisque j'ai ce rôle et que je
peux tout dire et que je lui étais pas
spécialement préparé
bah je vais dire je veux dire ce que
j'ai ressenti
je sais pas je peux a peut-être commencé
en parlons un peu de vous envoyer un
message à l'organisation c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu bizarre maintenant je
vois vraiment content que je suis sur
scène mais là ça va ya des gens qui me
regardent ya des gens qui me regardent
avec des gens qui me regardent mais là
pendant que je parle là bas au fond il
ya des gens qui regardent la télé bon ça
c'est assez bizarre et du coup je me
pose la question qu'est ce que c'est que
cette salle qu'est ce que c'est que
cette salle pourquoi l'année prochaine
vous organisez auriez pas ça dans une
piste de bobsleigh donc vous y êtes
alors c'est vrai
bon je vais commencer par vous dire que
finalement au début j'étais un petit peu
déçu quand vous avez expliqué ce que
c'était la différence entre les
conférences ted et les conférences tedx
parce que secrètement je pensais que
c'était la qualité des conférences ted
mais en parlant de pornographie
heureusement certains intervenants l'ont
abordé parce que sinon je pense que
j'aurais été hyper déçu et puis bah
finalement il s'est passé plein de
choses donc peut-être que ben on peut
peut-être faire ça je peux peut-être
regarder un peu dire ce que j'ai
ressenti en regardant les uns les autres
bon parce que m il ya des trucs c'était
bien mais y'a des trucs quand même un
bon et on va commencer par la première
bon johanna johanna franchement moi je
suis je suis venu déjà là j'ai pris une
grosse claque parce que johanna tu as
dit à un moment donné eh ben
souvenez-vous du moment vous a réalisé
vous avez réalisé que vous alliez mourir
merci bien mais moi je l'avais pas
encore réalisé donc déjà j'ai passé dix
minutes abad et dans mon coin quoi et
après comme si elle avait pas enfoncer
le couteau assez loin elle commence à
nous parler de la petite boule qu'elle a
dans la gorge
et là je trouve que ça aussi c'est pas
très sympa de le dire ce qu'il faut il
faut s'adresser il faut penser à son
public quand on dit des trucs parce que
franchement qui n'a pas l'habitude
d'avoir des boule dans la gorge plutôt
que les supporters du stade rennais
il ya des lieux pour dire les choses
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu as dit
encore
bon après à huy après oui c'est vrai tu
as parlé tes vacances en malaisie c'est
vrai hélas à ce moment là moi ça m'a
rappelé mes vacances au camping des au
camping des flots parce que j'étais
arrivé là bas puis en fait je lutte a
rendu compte que j'avais oublié mon
maillet et en ce gros choc j'ai oublié
mon mariage hétéro hyper embêter la paf
je suis posé plein de questions puis du
coup je me suis dit comment je vais
enfoncé mes sardines savate hyper
compliqué alors l'âge j'ai commencé à
faire le tour de ma tante puis au bout
d'un moment j'ai ici avec une chaussure
qui en fait il y avait un caillou donc
là je commençais à me dire mais ça va
pas du tout puis au bout d'un moment
finalement j'ai regardé puis j'ai vu que
personne n'était de sardines parce qu'il
n'est pas trop dedans et je m'en suis
sorti et là je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais eu accès au bonheur
même sans maillet
bon alors je réponds un peu dans les
autres qu'ils apparaissent alors jean
philippe jean philippe non mais sans
déconner jean-philippe mais c'est peu tu
peux pas dire des trucs comme ça c'est
donc jeté là jean philippe sauvin tu
m'as fait pleurer c'était hyper émouvant
merci beaucoup
bon tu m'as fait bander aussi après par
contre avec tout le respect que je te
dois je vraiment j'ai été ultra touch et
je ne pensais pas que les personnes
handicapées pouvait aussi touchante et
par contre c'est un truc qu'il faut que
tu t'expliques jeu j'en profite parce
que peut-être que ça va servir à
d'autres on se retrouve à un moment
donné je sais on a envie d'écrire des
lettres à des gens mais tu sais il ya
des moyens beaucoup plus simple que
d'inviter 600 personnes pour lire les
lettres alors que les gens sont là tu
peux utiliser la poste et puis leur
envoyer tu voir et en plus plutôt que
plus de 2 de condom convié autant de
monde en plus on n'a pas tous eu notre
lettre moi j'attendais ma lettre avec
une grande impatience
bon moi aussi j'aime je suis pas fan des
commodes mais ça c'est pas tellement ban
bon alors après il ya eu olivier olivier
qui nous a parlé que lui en fait quand
ils n'arrivent pas à faire un truc et
que les ordinateurs arrive pas à le
faire il le fait faire aux gamins et ça
non mais c'est vachement intéressant
parce que ils jouent donc ils se rendent
pas compte je veux dire ils sont eux ils
ils le font ils s'amusent et en plus ils
résolvent des trucs hyper important du
coup j'ai une suggestion pour la
prochaine expression je me dis que étant
donné que ni les ordinateurs ni nous les
adultes on arrive à résoudre ça
peut-être que vous pourriez les faire
travailler par exemple sur les violences
faites aux femmes ou ou un truc du genre
c'est moins drôle a alors après qui est
ce qu'on a eu on a une haleine
nolwenn nolwenn je suis désolé je sais
pas qui c'est qu'a laissé crier son
gamin au début de ton truc ça ça a dû
complètement perturbé mais bon tu t'es
bien reprises j'ai trouvé ça
complètement génial mais je tenais quand
même à te dire que moi j'ai du coup un
problème avec ma fille parce que ma
fille elle a simulé une appendicite
maintenant pour aller jouer aux jeux que
tu as m'occupais que tu as montré et
quand il lui retirer ce rendu compte
qu'elle n'était pas un flat mais bon
après qu'est-ce qu'on a eu encore
mimiche michael michael michael qui nous
parle de la scolarité
moi ça m'a fait un sacré choc parce que
lesdits souvenez vous de votre scolarité
bah ouais moi je voulais faire moi je
voulais faire ingénieurs mes parents ils
m'ont dit non tu seras comédien bon bah
j'ai tenu bon pendant un moment quoi
j'ai fait un ingénieur puis après bah
j'ai craqué j'ai fait comédien
après il ya eu berthier berthier il
était exceptionnel berthier pas ce qu'il
a dit un truc que j'ai adoré berthier il
a dit à un moment donné à différents on
se dit que c'est dire merde à tout le
monde et moi je trouve hallucinant qu'il
n'ait pas profité de l'occasion d'avoir
autant de personnes dans la pièce pour
le faire du coup j'en profite un peu
merde merde merde à après bah oui a eu
beau paul marquez duarte mais ça c'était
nul
quoi quoi mais non bien sûr j'ai été
touché paul j'aimerais que tu m'autorise
à utiliser ta machine je sais pas où tu
es mais j'ai vu qu'elle était partie
c'est dommage parce que moi j'avais un
message à adresser peut-être pas au
vieux sébastien chambre parce que je
suis mais j'aurais voulu parler avoue
sébastien chambre qui avait 18 ans parce
que quand je te vois tu vois je voudrais
me parler à moi quand j'avais 18 ans en
disant elle dit dont sébastien tu te
rends compte qu'à ton âge il y en a ils
sont déjà allés à cannes alors toi
qu'est ce que tu fous alors bouge toi le
cul parce que sinon à 38 ans tu vas
finir là tedx
bon et puis j'en oublie probablement un
bcc j'en suis désolé je peux pas je peux
pas donner mon avis surtout parce qu'il
faut qu'on rentre chez nous au bout d'un
moment et en fait ce que je regrette un
tout petit peu c'est que vous m'ayez pas
donner l'opportunité moi aussi de jouer
avec un truc comme ça parce que si vous
m'aviez demandé gentiment plutôt que de
me tirer au hasard
eh ben je vous assure je vous aurais
fait je vous aurais fait une conférence
j'en aurais fait un talk j'aurais fait
un truc genre effet hier une conférence
ce sera appelé les solutions 1 vous
aurez fait une conférence qui
s'appellerait les solutions par le
professeur sébastien chambre bon eh bien
je vais vous faire une conférence qui
s'appelle les solutions par le
professeur sébastien chabal ans le
professeur sébastien chambre sur un
petit abus et vous m'en excuserez c'est
simplement que je me suis dit que si je
voulais que les personnes intelligentes
dans la salle mais coûte il fallait que
je triche un petit peu sur ma condition
est donc là je me suis posé la question
en me disant est-ce qu'il faut mettre
une photo
parce que en asie faut pas faire de
powerpoint et de présentation quand on
va à tedx et en regardant ma conférence
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
et en fait au départ je me suis dit ça
sous faulx se présentait donc que je me
suis dit je met une photo alors je met
une photo oui mais quelle photo je suis
je veux est une photo de moi c'est au
ris pas original mais c'est ce qui me
représente le plus les à-côtés mon titre
professeur des universités là ça pète
parce que je pense que ça joue vachement
en fait qu'ils les autres sont ça joue
vachement sur la colle le crédit qu'on
va leur apporter
je me suis dit par exemple si j'allais
me sébastien chambre comédien et qu'est
ce qu'est ce que vous seriez discussions
oui beaucoup
qu'est ce qu'un comédien pourrait bien
vous apprendre cette bande de feignasses
du coup je suis mon jeu surtout pas que
jamais de ça je vais mettre autre chose
qui après je me suis dit mais allons
plus loin si on doit parler de soi est
ce que ça change l'image des autres si
j'avais mis sébastien chambre
homosexuels là je pense que la moitié
des gens se seraient dits bawedin
chemise rose
mais si j'avais mis sébastien chambre
schizophrène mal à des gens qui sont
assis à côté de moi là eh ben il se
serait dit waouh purée je viens de
passer quatre ans et demi à 6 à côté
d'un schizophrène parce qu'ils savent
pas ce que c'est forcément si j'avais
mis sébastien chambre a fait un burn-out
l'avouer mais peut-être que vous seriez
en train de vous dire tiens c'est con
mais je trouvais cool le type là je le
ferai bien venir pour faire une
conférence quelque part mais il doit pas
être fiable puisqu'il a fait un burn-out
pour peu que sa tombe le jour où j'ai
besoin de lui et ben non pas du coup bah
non râpez non alors du coup je me dis
faut peuvent pas mettre sa peut-être que
je pourrai mettre sébastien chambre sort
avec une noire et là à ce moment-là
peut-être il ya des gens qui se serait
du bon moi ça me dérange pas trop
et du coup je me suis posé la question
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient dit si j'avais
dit qui sort avec un noir
alors là je me suis dit voilà c'est
quand même cumulé un peu les mandats
donc je me suis dit il faut que je
change mes yeux ou alors du coup
peut-être que je pourrai avoué
finalement que je suis une femme et que
je m'appelle sébastienne chambre s et là
je devine déjà un peu tout ce que vous
diriez un peu du genre oh là là là
pauvre la tronche qu'elle se paye
comment elle va faire pour faire un
métier de douceur comme infirmière ou
institutrice avec une tête comme ça et
surtout comment va-t-elle faire pour
trouver un mari 1
la pauvre bon du coup c'est pour ça que
j'ai mis professeur sébastien chambre le
solution alors pourquoi ben oui pourquoi
les solutions c'est très important
pourquoi les solutions parce qu'on parle
toujours de problèmes la différence ça
crée des problèmes on sait pas comment
gérer les problèmes
et bien moi aujourd'hui je vais régler
vos problèmes en vous apportant les
solutions
alors les soumissions c'est une
conférence assez courtes qui va avoir en
gros trois parties la première partie on
va parler de quoi qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
la deuxième partie on va parler de
caisse que quoi qu'on va faire pour
qu'ils aient enfin en troisième partie
comment qu'est ce qu'on doit le faire et
je vous dis tout de suite que peut-être
vous est posée la question de pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on va le faire pour qui
mais ça c'est pas intéressant
l'important c'est d'agir il faut le
faire maintenant
alors quoi qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
puisque je suis un professeur j'ai
choisi de vous faire un graphe moche sur
ce gratte moi je vous verrai deux axes
le premier axe nous allons regarder le
niveau de dangerosité des solutions à ce
qu'elles sont dangereuses ou pas et sur
un deuxième acte la difficulté à mettre
en oeuvre ces solutions tout d'abord
facile non difficile à mettre en oeuvre
mais pas dangereux les avancées
scientifiques les avancées scientifiques
sont fabuleux c'est ce qui nous permet
de savoir que le cerveau de la femme est
le cerveau de l'homme ils sont
strictement identiques et que c'est une
question de plastique et qu'en fait
c'est une question d'éducation et que si
mesdames vous ne savez pas faire de
créneaux ce n'est pas parce que vous
n'avez pas la vision dans l'espace parce
que tout ça c'est des conneries c'est
également grâce aux avancées
scientifiques qu'on sait que l'autisme
et génétique et que vous n'avez rien à
voir mesdames vous n'êtes pas coupable
parce que ce qu'on racontait la
psychanalyse pendant des années après
ces avancées scientifiques pour pouvez y
aller un petit avion merci merci
les avancées scientifiques séduire à
mettre en oeuvre mais quelque chose de
facile à mettre en oeuvre
l'éducation la formation l'information
parce qu'il suffit d'en parler c'est
simplement parce qu'on sait pas ce que
c'est qu'on en a peur et qu'on se
comportent comme des connards alors
qu'il suffit de poser des questions et
d'expliquer aux gens qu'on est tous
super cool
des fois et puis bien sûr à notre truc
c'est bas tout ce qu'on n'a pas encore
inventé et qu'on n'a pas encore pensé
qu'il faut toujours se laisser un peu de
place pour l'amélioration des choses
alors tout ceci c'est bien beau vous me
direz parce que ça s'est écrasé par le
fg c'est le fg c'est le fg c'est qui
prend alors le fg c'est j'ai pas pu le
mettre à l'échelle parce que j'avais pas
assez de place disons que si j'avais dû
mettre le fg c'est à l'échelle
il faut imaginer que les autres kkr et
ont la bonne taille
mais le fg s'est fait à peu près la
taille de la france alors qu'est ce que
le fg c'est me direz vous et bien c'est
le facteur gros connard
car il faut le savoir la connerie est la
ressource la mieux distribuée sur la
planète
vous pouvez partir n'importe où en
oubliant votre connerie vous en
trouverez sur place et quel que soit
votre gourmandise en conneries il y en
aura toujours trop dont allégi le
facteur gros con qu'est-ce que ça peut
bien être des fois c'est des gens qu'on
aime et moi par exemple je vous parlais
de quelqu'un que j'adore et que si
jamais tu regarde cette vidéo un jour tu
sais que je t'aime beaucoup je vais vous
parler de ma grand mère ma grand mère a
ouais ça vous demandez ce que je vais
dire comme saloperies sur ma grand-mère
et vous avez raison car ma grand-mère
quelqu'un que j'adore vraiment un jour a
dit pas je rentre du centre-ville et
j'ai vu une personne se garer sur une
place handicapée avec un macaron
handicapés et la personne elle est
sortie de sa voiture en marchant comme
quoi quand même ces gens là ils abusent
bon j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que
peut être cette personne là pouvait pas
marcher longtemps parce qu'elle avait
des problèmes de dos et que tous les
handicaps ne se voyait pas mais eux
alors maintenant je voudrais vous
montrer des méthodes j'ai parlé de
solutions on ya toujours des problèmes
on parler de problème moi je sais ça
vous êtes tous arrivés ça nous est tous
arrivé c'est pénible on se coltine des
gens qui sont en état dépressif majeur
les gens qui font des dépressions c'est
insupportable et bien maintenant je vais
vous le dire comment faire pour se
comporter avec une personne en état
dépressif
c'est ça vous vous le demandiez
aujourd'hui c'est moi je vous l'offre
c'est cadeau c'est la méthode
alors tout d'abord écouter la personne
autant que possible il est important que
vous puissiez faire une investigation
pour essayer de trouver quel est son
mal-être afin de l'aider à le résoudre
deuxièmement l'aider à réaliser des
tâches qu'elles n'arrivent pas à faire
seul parce que c'est toujours hyper
valorisant de se faire aider par
quelqu'un qui est toujours juste
derrière en train de demander si on
arrive à faire nos lacets troisième
point
troisième point la motivait pour voir
des gens pour faire du sport penser
positif et si besoin des un petit coup
de pied au cul ça fait jamais de mal
il faut bouger les gens et oui il faut
se prendre par la main si tout ça ne
marche pas il faut diffuser des huiles
essentielles de patchouli en grande
quantité vous trouverez ça dans la
première pharmacie
c'est ça marche toujours pas faut lui
faire la liste de tout ce qui va bien
dans sa vie parce que bon faut
relativiser quand même
tout le monde a ses petits problèmes
donc aider la personne dit lui bah ouais
mais regarde un peu tout pour toi quand
même alors un bon et si vraiment ça
marche pas et bien vous lui montrerez un
film sur la shoah pour l'aider à
relativiser parce qu'il faut toujours
penser un petit peu aux gens qui sont
plus malheureux que soi
et si tout ça n'a pas marché et bien
vous pourrez lui lire le passage de la
bible ezéchiel 25-17 de la bible édition
boutin
car c'est toujours rassurant de trouver
des gens qui disent plus je te crois
briques vous bon alors bien sûr vous
pourrez dire ah oui d'accord mais l'état
dépressif mais moi si je connais un
bipolaire à et bien rassurez vous je
vous dites tout ça dans mon livre qui
s'appelle comment gérer les handicapés
bien sûr par le professeur sébastien
chambre c'est aux éditions bras c'est
parce qu'ils coûtent horriblement cher
mais il est vraiment bien
il vous le faut acheter mon livre bon
bien sûr ça c'est des conneries c'est
des conneries mais pourquoi je vous dis
ça parce qu'effectivement je suis
comédien et que je joue dans un
spectacle qui s'appelle tous pareils
tous différents et où on essaie de
changer le regard des gens sur les
personnes en situation de handicap parce
qu'on est tous concernés et que en fait
ça c'est ce qu'on nous demande quand on
va faire le spectacle en 10 s qu'à la
fin vous nous donnerez un petit
fascicule on nous explique comment se
comporter avec les différentes
pathologies
versez pas des personnes
1 comment gérer les personnes servies
aux mêmes parce que les personnes
handicapées ou en situation de handicap
et ben y'a pas besoin de les gérer et se
gère très bien tout seul donc du coup
j'aimerais changer un petit peu retiré
mon tablier de professeurs est passé aux
citoyens sébastien champ pour vous faire
part une petite réflexion
cette petite réflexion c'est le fait
seront se rendre compte que ben certain
moment on est un peu tous pareils on est
un peu tous pareils on a tous plus ou
moins eu des cheveux vont peut-être pas
vous mais mais quand on a faim on aime
bien manger un truc qu'on a envie de
faire pipi
on aime bien aller aux toilettes quand
on est amoureux on est content sens mais
là où on en parle à tout le monde
pierre france fait larguer en tire la
gueule il ya des moments on est un peu
tous pareils mais à des moments et ben
on est on est un peu tous différents ça
peut être une manière de s'habiller
ça peut être une orientation sexuelle ça
peut être une couleur de la peau ça peut
être un handicap ça peut être un genre
ça peut être le pays d'où on vient la
langue maternelle
ça peut être n'importe quoi mais en fait
on s'en fout parce que le truc le plus
important c'est en fait qu'on est tous
égaux
on est tous égaux et même les connards
parce qu'en fait on est quand même tous
un peu des connards moi je suis un
connard personnellement je le sais très
bien je réponds jamais à mes mails je
réponds jamais à rien dès que je vais
quelque part j'arrive une heure en
retard
et puis mais c'est pas grave parce que
les gens et même quand même un petit peu
des fois et met tout le monde un connard
vous vous êtes une [ __ ] parce que
mais si mais si en plus vous le savez
vous vous le savez vous vous êtes un
connard mais bon vous ça se voit en même
temps vous vous aussi nos visées tous
des connards on est tous des connards
lui vaut aussi qu'il nous regarde et
vous chez vous là vous êtes des connards
et des [ __ ] et vous le savez très
bien vous là bas sinon vos fauteuils
fait semblant de d'écouté alors vous
dormez vous êtes aussi des connards et
des [ __ ] mais c'est pas très grave
parce que je voudrais vous dire vraiment
quelque chose
le plus sincèrement possible c'est de
vous dire que vous êtes je vous connais
pas vous êtes des connards vous êtes des
[ __ ] je voudrais quand même vous
dire ce que je pense a priori parce que
c'est mon choix et pour vous dire ça je
voudrais demander de l'aide de beaucoup
de personnes que de comédiens et de
comédiennes que j'ai rencontré à des
moments c'est de vous dire que vous êtes
des connards mais je vous aime
il n'y a pas de mémoire constantinois à
amiens york tandis qu'ailleurs fixing un
annuaire hamad dans la bio analyse à
l'avion est la ville où est ma bio ou
pas bio
merci beaucoup